hey there and welcome to pro flows plus
i'm cameron and this is part two of our
more advanced lesson for title okay so
one thing looking at this a couple
things i immediately see is uh number
one i want this to be white i don't want
it to be
this kind of yellowish white
so that's the first i'm going to do is
i'm going to go to my title light
hit a a and i'm going to change
the color here to 100 white
that looks a little bit better
i also
definitely do not want to see this
background
texture here
once we get to this point so i think
that's just me saying except lights on
it's gone and we just need to make sure
at some point we can see it
which we can't really see it and i don't
know if that's because
i'm gonna go ahead and scale it back
down to a hundred percent here
i also want it to be closer to our guy
here because i want to really highlight
him
so
maybe somewhere in here
but it's interesting because i can't
really see it
maybe
let's open this back up except lights on
except shadows
just to make sure let's just turn that
off
okay yeah there's no shadows
cache shadows
ambience up there
maybe
sometimes playing around with these like
turning diffuse all the way up is
definitely doing something here
uh specular metal maybe sometimes
turning it down
[Music]
but i don't like that
so i'm not sure what that is
so let's bring it a little bit
further
so when it's back here behind the guy
you can definitely see it it's hitting a
light there but i don't like that at all
so it looks like
i think we need to add a light
and we'll call this a point light as
well we'll make it white
and this will be the
subtle
dust light
and
we don't need to catch shadows again
so that definitely brought some
light into it let's take it up here
and i don't want it to affect that the
guy the man
let's turn the brightness of it down
let's go ahead and scale up
back up there so i'm just looking at the
edges here i just want to make sure i'm
not
i just don't want to see
the edges here
and i also want it to fade out
again like once we get to this point i
want it to be gone
so to do that we're just going to
keyframe the intensity so here
it's 25 but by the time it hits here
it's down to zero
maybe it's negative 10.
so it's just a very subtle effect
but it works right
okay so something else i want to do is i
want to bring in a little bit more
texture here
and i to do that it's going to be real
simple we're just going to drop in an
entire layer here's where i'm bringing
old design
right there boom and let's just copy
these three effects
put it on here
and there we go and we'll set it to
screen
and we'll make it three dimensional
so it
sees some of those lights there
nice
and we're gonna bring it forward
maybe
somewhere right in here
and bring it down
oh somewhere maybe in there
yeah so that just gives a lot more
atmosphere there
and i want to make sure at this point
that we're not seeing it so we are
seeing a little bit of there
so maybe if i push it back
i really like the position there so
let's just make sure
where was our negative light where is
that at
oh negative light
so negative 48 so maybe if i go even
more
it's interesting if you go really
negative you can start seeing these come
back as a negative value as black
i don't want that
yeah so the negative light's not going
to work for that one
so maybe for this guy we just do a
little bit of a cheat here
so we have 100 opacity and then we just
drop that opacity down to zero
or not i guess yeah okay that is it
right there
but we're still seeing something else
right in there which i believe
looks to me like another texture layer
so what is that
it's not that
so it's none of those three maybe it's
one of this
that's that one right there
so again maybe for this guy we'll do the
same thing we'll have 100 opacity
and then just drop them to zero
i just want it to be
you know just the focus is on the title
sometimes it's okay if there's a little
bit of texture there
but i just want that title to really
come through
so that's looking pretty nice this line
of text right here is bugging me
let's move it up because i just want to
see
i don't want it to cover the guys
yeah it just bugs me how it covers him
up right there
maybe just a hair more
so you remember that we started with him
completely uh
black everything was black to start with
so we do need to
adjust some of the the lights here
something that we added
is really bringing some light so there
there's one of them
so if we maybe have this one start at
zero
what else we got going on here we have
another
it could be our texture here
and that's adding a little bit
let's turn these lights off
those are adding a little bit as well so
we'll
hit a a
and we'll set their intensities
to
zero as well
i could also just add like a black solid
here to fade everything in
which maybe i will actually do that
but i'll make it
very quick so we'll i like to call it
fade in and put at the top of the layer
stack here
hit t for transparency
and by a second in i want it to be gone
option in bracket to
set the out point and i'll lock this
layer so i don't
mess with it there
yeah now the only thing that's bothering
me now is that this guy is out of focus
and he should you know really be in
focus right at this point so let's look
at
that our focus distance is 620
at the end
so a lot of times what i'll do like what
you just saw me do there is i set
and i do this all the time like lights
and things like that if i like a setting
of where it's at but i know i'm going to
adjust and add some other keyframes i'll
just immediately set a keyframe and then
i'll just drag that keyframe out
wherever so it's out there
i know that i want to get to that point
eventually which is why it's there so
that's what i just did there
and let's just set a
focus distance here so the guy is right
here
and our camera is way back here so
you know something else we can look at
is if i hit shift p
maybe we just need to bring the camera
closer there's more of a move here
you know something like
maybe this
that's not too bad
let's go bring the focus distance in
and we'll do an ease into this
so i want to get this stuff out of focus
pretty quickly
[Music]
okay that's looking pretty cool
so now let's add some a few things here
to kind of really you know finish this
off oh actually you know what i forgot
is to add this air particles windy
footage here
this stuff's pretty cool
[Music]
you can see it's just some air particles
kind of flying through space here and i
just want to see them in the middle here
somewhere
and this is also 4k footage so it's huge
let's go back to two views make sure
we've got some lights hitting this
so i can see a little bit right
i thought i did
hey i'm going to turn the diffuse up to
100
[Music]
yeah i'm just not seeing this one at all
there it starts to come in
so i want to see it just before we see
that type come in
and i've lost it i had it there for a
second
tell you what when you work with a lot
of lights like this
it's easy to
lose track of what
what you can see and what you can't see
here
shoot
there's our dust right there you can see
a little speck that comes through right
here you know that might be kind of
interesting to see some of this dust
here at the end with the title
yeah so maybe we'll try that
let's um add just a few things here to
finish this off that's going to be a new
adjustment layer
and we'll call that effects
we'll bring it below the fade in
and for this i want to add some green i
want this to have like a nice organic
feel to it and that's going to require
some grain so let's add some
green
[Music]
set that to final output
let's go back to one view
[Music]
and let's set the preset to the second
one i found that this was pretty nice
very subtle but it's nice
let's also add a chromatic aberration
which you know it's very huge right now
it's very trendy
um like i said you can add plug in
everything quick chromatic aberration
that's a free plug-in i'm going to
actually use red giant universe
we're going to switch it up this time
and we're going to go into
[Music]
actually under distort chromatic
aberration
this is one i've used very little of
i typically will use sapphire
but let's go with this for this project
you can see i brought it above
below add grain so i want grain to be
the final kind of effect on on top of
everything i want it to be on top of
that chromatic aberration
so you don't want to have grain and then
chromatic aberration on top of that i
mean i guess you could
but for me
i want that green to be on the
tops so i like how this is really
distorting on the edge here
i don't want it to be too heavy
i think simple
or simple smudges is where i'm going to
go here
yeah i think simple smudges will work
for me
it's looking pretty good i like how it
kind of gives that edge that blurry edge
to it
it's looking pretty nice
and i also want to add i think just a
little bit of flicker here
and to add a little bit of flicker let's
actually go to a new solid
make it slightly off white here
a little bit on the orange side
and we'll call this flicker
and we're gonna set the transparency
really low here like
two percent
we're gonna hit alt or option click
wiggle
and let's just do a low value two and
three and see what that looks like
actually let's do six and three
six and three is what i found worked
pretty well for my
test i'm gonna save this
okay so let's take a look at this it's
looking pretty
dope which is my favorite word
um i like it there's always things i'm
going to adjust
the one thing i don't two things i don't
love i don't love
this dust that's kind of flying the
windy dust here i'm going to go ahead
and include it in the project file for
my final version i'm going to turn it
off
something else i want to do is i want to
actually bring the effects above the
flicker so the flicker was very subtle
there
i could actually even
turn up the transparency
maybe just a hair more
and then on the effects i'm actually
going to turn this master distortion way
down
yeah something like that point one uh
you saw that it was default
even at simple
uh distortion was default to a master
distortion of one and i'm just turning
that down to 0.1
and i think that's going to do it for me
i do see a little bit of a black edge
here which i don't absolutely love
i don't know if that's yeah that's the
chalkboard so i'm gonna scale that up
let's just go to 200 there we go so
that's going to fill in the frame
and obviously this could be any title
you think it might be
that might look good you could always
add additional effects things like that
you know something i might
do is
i don't
love
the
kind of yellowish light that's going on
a lot here i think it's
a little bit stronger
as
a white light
so just bring it a little bit more in
that area i'm just hitting aaa
it's just subtle
so those two are good
the ambient fill i never used negative
light i didn't use right i am using but
the color doesn't matter on that one man
spotlight i'm gonna bring that one a
little bit more
in the white range there
[Music]
that looks good
and
[Music]
the flicker i'm actually going to also
bring it
more in the white range right there
and with that i'm going to turn off my
air particles
set this to render and i'm going to call
this one good
uh as always
let me see what you create you know this
project file is there for you to work
off of but i love it when you
uh take this and you make it your own
right don't just take the project file
and replace some text or replace an
image or replace the final
title
you know make it your own take what
you've learned here and change some
things up and just make it make it your
own piece and put that out on social
media on instagram hashtag it proflos
plus tag motion science and let me see
what you create
and that's going to wrap up this lesson
on
advanced
3d lights and shadows
[Music]
you